karl rove is the former white house
deputy chief of staff
george w bush and a fox news contributor
all right carl am i being too tough on
these guys is this all this thing one
big coincidence
well you know the one senator who got
back to you tom carper said it was his
financial advisor he's got a trust a
blind trust now it doesn't mean he
doesn't know what's in it because that
blind trust has to report all of its
trades but he doesn't make those
decisions they're made by his investment
trustee and if the investment trustee is
getting advice from carper if carver is
telling him go go and invest in the in
the fertilizer manufacturer it's a
violation of the law and that guy would
lose his license and his livelihood if
he did it so
when i was in the white house i had to
sell
can i just add one thing our team here
says that if it's in a blind trust it
doesn't have to be disclosed yet this
was disclosed that's not accurate that's
not accurate but members of congress
have to have their their all of their
trades disclosed if they're in a trust
the trustee has to provide that
information so they could be then it
could be a firm but no there's there's
no you'll have to take it up with the
closure
i did i did earlier today
with all due respect to all the brains
of the brain room i think they're wrong
on this one okay but look when i when i
was at the white house i had to sell all
my individual stocks
i was allowed to hold broadly based
mutual funds that were on you know in
essence on an approved list that that
may be one way to deal with congress on
the other hand i'm not in favor of
saying that members of congress can't
invest in the market
i would rather that they either be
forced to do it through
like white house staff and do it through
broadly based mutual funds or all of
them be required to do it through
through
trustees blind trust but i don't want
congress to be only limited to people
who are hermits and and and are not
investors in the great american economy
let me just let me just get karl rove's
opinion on on just an example
we're in a run-up to a war
and they're on these subcommittees on
energy and national security and they're
getting briefings for months and months
they're getting intelligence they're
getting briefings
and some of these democrats
they're buying oil companies
they're buying drilling companies
all the while biden's saying we're
bringing gas prices down and you guys
need to buy electric cars they're not
buying tesla they're buying energy and
drilling companies here
and they're buying fertilizer companies
come on carl
you're not saying you're not seeing
anything a little bit sketchy about
what's going on here and they're not
warning they're not warning the rest of
the american public what's coming down
the pipeline
we got two different things here we got
we got people buying stocks
that are in violation if you will of
their own self-professed views i'm for
green energy i'm for the green new deal
and yet i'm buying a diamondback energy
which incidentally has one of the
coolest uh uh symbols on on the entire
wall street the diamondback energy
symbol is fang f-a-n-g so
i think that is a problem we can hold
them up as being guilty of hypocrisy if
if you if you're if you want to make
public policy for the rest of the
country that that is anti-energy you
better not be buying energy companies
now but but the other one i'm not i'm
not buying i'm not buying that we have
evidence that they were sitting there
saying you know what i know for fact
certain that we're going to have a an
invasion in in it i'm sitting here in
january and on january 10th and i'm
going to buy a fertilizer stock because
i'm you know or in that case it was the
trustee okay because i know there's
going to be a problem and we're going to
have our supplies of of of of fertilizer
cut off and i'm not confident
i'm not convicting anybody on the air of
insider trading i'm saying we have
information and we're putting the
information out there and this is not
the first day we're going to do it we're
going to do it
many days next week and it's a pattern
and we've shown the pattern and we're
going to continue to show the american
people and let the people decide what
they want and that's all we're doing all
right
you bet all right karl rove thank you so
much
you bet thank you